hi it's John Hope Bryant i'm the founder
of operation home and the vice chairman
of the US presidents council on
financial literacy or had the honor of
devising President Clinton President
Bush and now I'm serving president obama
is vice-chairman to 2010 so I've watched
your video creative scientists on moral
currency and I'm only speaking for
myself here now make a clear I'm
speaking as an individual but I was
inspired by your concept I think it may
be complicated in in the elegant way in
which you outline it for it to be
implemented although I think that a
version of it is implemented already
it's called a failure of country why
it's called the failure of interim in
other words the market has already paid
a text on unscrupulous companies that
have economically raped and pillaged
consumers when the only equation is an
economic equation when there is only a
financial agenda a money agenda not a
prosperity agenda and ideas agenda an
empowerment agenda a service agenda when
you don't live with something large and
more important yourself well before you
go far after the North Pole you end up
south you out and they just outright in
your course I think is also another
moral courage it's called financial
losses one of the things that I believe
will happen as a result of this crisis
well what did this happen is it got
people like you exercise and and we're
having really a crisis of values in the
US and around the world because we put
all our stock in things and as you said
we didn't value if you look at some of
the gangster rap on TV they glorify a
dollar whether it's made selling crack I
mean the rose royce is by the same
dollar with its crack or whether you're
a scientist no pun intended and i think
that in the last twenty years my friend
quincy jones says we make dumb sexy
what about this one minute we dumb down
with our communities are our kids are
really almost adopted and culture it's
laziness and it's just you know how do I
get paid today so in the last twenty
years we made dumb sexy in the next 20
years we need to make smart sexy again
so we need to flip the script financial
literacy is a way to flip the script but
it wasn't important before with this
global economic crisis everybody
understands inter between a payment and
an interest rate the problem is that
people didn't ask what the payment was
the interest rate was but bought homes
from sometimes from unscrupulous
predatory lenders and asked only what
the payment was so we were taking
advantage of but we participated in that
we contributed room at and so we need to
have a new civil right and that's
financial literacy for all we need to
have a new serum or write a bank account
for every person put the payday lenders
and the check cashers audience
cookieless financial creditors ghettoize
financial services what amount of
business using free enterprise and
capitalism in every person electronic
FDIC insured bank account and stream the
payments from the Treasury for Social
Security and other paintings through
that bank account extreme financial
literacy for the bank account and
literally put the unscrupulous financial
creditors out of a 10 billion dollar a
year business so you have a choice to
make in other words it's not just the
government your moral your moral
currency argument it was placed at least
I framed I heard it is almost
responsible government question is what
can you do there's only so much
President Obama is going to be able to
do there's only so much that any
government they'll be able to do but
Gandhi once said that you'll be the
change you want to see in the world you
can make a choice you can make a choice
not to do business with predators and to
honor companies that honor you and your
community the companies that do well and
do good or concern about the brand and
reputation I guess the last point I'll
make is that this we've got a massive
massive pullback consumer confidence
well that's also tied to financial
literacy and so companies that can
realize that they have any concerned
about
not just a transaction but the long-term
relationship if we treat our clients
like relationships and not just as
transactions you don't do business with
a day you do business for a lifetime
that's doing well by doing good I
commend you for your concept of moral
currency you can I encourage you to go
out and teach a class with an H
illiteracy today in your community or
joint operation hope become a hope
remember because you're certainly
qualified god bless you from Davos and
thanks for your passion